[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the squad ride
live brought to you by draftkings live
in the bleacher report app
the most important decision you're gonna
make today is helping us
pick our week one nfl squad ride bet
we asked you on social media who's a lot
to score a touchdown this week
love all the comments you guys have
flooded the comment section already on
the app
beautiful you responded and here are
some of our favorite contenders
your favorite contenders actually you
saw this graphic on br betting's on the
socials
and look at these eight studs i feel
like
any one of these cats is a lot today on
week one nfl sunday
but that's what we've got these are some
of our favorites we've picked three
of our favorites to be featured on the
show and we're going to share those with
you
and let you pick your favorite whatever
you decide
we're riding as a family because that's
how we do debbie yes
yes yes jimmy g jimmy g was jimmy d
wasn't on there
i didn't see g uh jimmy g i didn't see
devos samuels i did see george kittle
though
but uh you know we'll see how gpg does
against the cardinals today
um we are getting an odds boost from our
friends at draftkings
so one of the three pitches that we
receive is gonna get a boost from draft
cake so thank you very much for that
to help you make this very important
decision we've got our betting expert
our mvp
kelly stewart and the babyface assassin
from the yuria
greg ivory my name is cabbie richards
uh the squad's fate is ultimately in
your hands
so get in the hot the comments we want
hot takes great picks
and shout out to mikey lox and vern who
say
who preach we want good vibes only
we definitely want those babies on
football
uh you know we're gonna be giving away a
bunch of hoodies i'm gonna be monitoring
the comments
and you know what in fact i'm in a
giving mood already so
i'm just going to give a a a hoodie to a
random commenter
uh i like um i like this guy's or this
person's handle
neck bone neck bone says josh jacobs is
going to score a touchdown for the
raiders today
neck bone you are getting a hoodie so
thank you for that
um all right it's time to hear our first
of three pitches
the notorious zach is gonna try to
convince you
to follow his lead on our week one squad
ride
so drop your reactions in the comments
after you hear
the notorious zack who think
and who does he think he's going to
score a touchdown ezekiel elliott is
absolute locked to score a touchdown
this week
why every once dallas is so loaded they
got jared judy they got
everybody it's mike mccarthy he's back
he's back everyone's expecting him to
air that ball out
back contract here trying to get paid no
they're gonna stick to the ground and
pound ezekiel's elite
back in the league he has killer
instincts
he's going to eat
[Laughter]
he brought out the cereal oh cabbie i
forgot what he said because he confused
me when he said the cowboys had jerry
judy
when they're when he's on the broncos
yeah it was
totally threw me off look i mean is zeke
gonna score a touchdown sure i like the
over
in that sunday night game in order to
hit those numbers i'm going to need a
lot of touchdowns from a lot of
different guys
that's a powerful old line if everybody
stays healthy today
i think they are going to feed zeke the
ball i like i like that
i like this big kelly kelly i'm right
there with you
i do see in order for the cowboys to win
today
ezekiel elliott needs to have a good
game he needs to get in the end zone
he needs to score so i i don't like d
i don't dislike the bet but my only
thing is kelly
look at the juice minus 225
i mean that's a lot to lay so i don't
know i i i just don't know
you know greg as our wise friend mikey
locks always says juice only hurts if it
loses
i think that was his quote uh all joke
all jokes aside i do have my concerns
with aaron donald uh coming up the
middle there
and just punching zeke in the gut that
that kind of pass rush
usually doesn't affect running backs too
bad but i could see him making some big
stops today
uh we got some we got some fire comments
i like shy town 45
says say quads barkley appreciate that
uh there's another dude uh ben ramble
says alvin kamara receiving touchdown
book it
which is in oh shout out to your guys
raheem moster
uh sparta says he'll find the end zone
um
and then uh zach moss zach moss t
so uh joe yan says zach moss td for
cabbie since buffalo so close to canada
i appreciate that seattle is also close
but buffalo is closer to toronto than
seattle is to vancouver
but thank you and uh uh nichola twenty
thank you
geography lessons this morning that's
how you that's how we do on
squad ride and uh ninja 23 says g little
will go off we'll go off today so uh i
think maybe he meant george kittle not g
little but either way i just read the
comments um
and then mikey lotto back in the
comments gronk is scoring a touchdown
today
shout out to you um there i
one one commenter and i just missed him
said nobody wants to see zeke eating
cereal today
shout out to zach i like how he
punctuated the comments and
maybe he was inspired by steve belichick
the new england patriots safety
and defensive coach because he he we
were the world was introduced to him
last year and he had the flowing mullet
so mate zach is you know he's obviously
giving his cowboys
he's channeling his inner kinney powers
over there
that dark curly mullet uh it it just
makes me
think of that show he's pounding down
and then he's just eating
gross cereal on video and i'm just here
we are
we i've i've seen a few zeke elliott
touchdowns but i've seen a lot
joe mix an easy touchdown there's a
there's a lot of people
um yeah the the picks are very
okay let's um let's go let's move on to
our uh you know what uh i got a shout
out before we continue i gotta shout out
uh stephen bondur
who was a uh who was in my dms earlier
in the week and he reminded me of hoodie
happy hour again we used to play in the
spring
so before we continue let's play some
trivia let's just shout out to hoodie
happy hour
so thank you steven bonder for the nice
reminder so here's how it works i have a
trivia question you guys get in the
comments answer the trivia question
i have a hoodie to give away a little
bit later in the show the question is
who is tom brady's mlb hall of fame
landlord in tampa bay who's his land
this
is easy right it is easy it's been it's
been well documented
get in the comments i'm gonna give away
a hoodie a little bit later on
uh if you have the correct answer what
do you guys think tom brady's rent is
before we continue
kelly more than greg's salary for a year
oh 10 times my salary but if we combine
all of ours it'll probably be like three
to five times
all of our salary okay that's excessive
greg
gabby makes a lot of money here i make
it i make it in canadian
which is lovely all right let's uh back
to our pitches which is 30
off um we're asking you to decide our
week one squad ride
remember to drop your takes in the
comments there are a lot of fire hot
takes which i appreciate
your favorite bet is gonna get a boost
from our friends at draftkings which is
dope
so you heard zach try to sell you on
ezekiel elliott now it's time to hear
from our friend tiff
aka pix by chicks
you guys christian mccaffrey is
definitely the move here
he is the best running back in the
league he can even make plays as a
receiver
he's pretty much the only person on the
panthers that can score
they're going up against a raider team
who quite frankly sucks
year after year so this is really a
no-brainer
lock it in christian mccaffrey
yo shout out to
pigs by chicks i am loving that pic
i do think christian mccaffrey needs to
have a big game in order for the
panthers to win today
but also they're playing the raiders the
and the raiders are the favorite kelly
can you believe that the raiders are the
favorite on the road
i'm rocking with the panthers here man i
can see them
showing up at home getting this win
kelly what do you think like talk to me
the raiders
are the favorites greg it's it's weird
right so the raiders opened so the week
one lines have been out for a long time
the raiders opened as a small underdog
tons of money came in on them i think
the hype is is somewhat real i do think
the raiders are going to be improved
but we're asking them with limited
practice limited mini camp to travel to
carolina
to get up big for this game did
everybody just all of a sudden start to
sleep on teddy bridgewater
i don't get it here this dude filled in
for drew brees so nicely last year for
the saints
coupled with christian mccaffrey running
the ball giving him a break
behind center there i really think that
this is a good pick i like tiffany's
pick here and if
draftkings wants to give us a good odds
boost i think this is the one we have to
pick squad
this hey kelly i'm right there with you
hey i like the minus 250 because i
know this is a lot raiders
the raiders also feature four new
defensive starters and their newest
acquisition corey litter john at
linebacker is gonna have his hands full
with
one of the four four players in the
madden 99 club
it would be sick if cmc just came out in
the gold cliques
just for the warm-ups as an absolute
flex
um so the comments there are some
amazing ones carson reed says
oh actually i shouldn't give this away
yet but um empath great comment aaron
jones
two touchdowns today one rushing one
receiving
that's fire um let me yo let me get that
hoodie
uh who else i got uh d-boy one
d-boy 510 just says raiders
shout out to you i don't know if you're
in vegas or oakland uh
refreshing these these comments are
coming in like
uh like crazy and i'm trying to oh i
just there was a dude
there's a commenter whose handle was
turtle pimp turtle pimp i'm gonna follow
you because that is the hilarious
uh hilarious handle um
oh and and josh beau 88 says more like
plus minus three tds for mccaffrey i
appreciate that that's some
that is some confidence in cmc who is
what i think he's
like what minus what is it plus 5 000
kells for
this season's mvp it's a super long shot
but maybe worthwhile
it is a long shot count because running
backs don't win mvp i think ladainian
tomlinson was the last one to do it so
it
it the odds are going to be long for a
reason that means we need a lot of
quarterbacks to do badly and christian
mccaffrey
to ball absolutely okay yes and he's
going to start off he's going to start
off today with a touchdown i'm i'm
locking it in okay i like that
i like it when you drop your locks but
yeah we got a bunch of locks in here
there's another one akante one says
kylie murray all right
so two pictures have been made the
notorious zach is on ezekiel elliott we
just heard from our friend tiff
aka picks by chicks who believes that
christian mccaffrey like many of you
guys in the comments
will score a touchdown today in his home
stadium
against the raiders keep dropping your
your takes in the hoodie in the comments
i've got hoodies to give away all right
so here is your third
and final final pitch at tyler wong
the stage is yours my friend
what's up vr betting currently at work
right now but i just wanted to give you
a quick pick for this sunday
and say that my guy draws kittle he's
guaranteed to get a touchdown
yo my guy my channel in this
inner charles barkley there my guy is
saving lives
and dropping locks let's go george
kittle to get into the end zone today
i don't dislike this bet but i will
stay away from the game the plus seven
i don't know kelly i'm staying away
being an iron fan i'm staying away from
the game
but george kittle too get in the end
zone that got me
thinking a little bit that got me
thinking a little bit george kittle does
need to get
uh active he needs to be one of the key
players for the niners in order for us
to get this win today so
i don't know i might be liking this one
this one might won me over
yeah greg listen i'm with you this sorry
kathy this is a stay away game for me as
well
i wanted to back the niners here i
really did but divisional
week one underdogs have covered at such
a great clip
for the last four or five seasons it's
hard for me to step in front of that
train
i do think your niners will get the w
here
but man what do we look at here we have
no depot samuel
we rahim mozart was mentioned earlier
george kittle's pretty much going to be
his number one if not number two target
today
we'll see i know a lot of people are
concerned with that super bowl hangover
i think that the niners
will be just fine but george kettle will
score a touchdown yeah i like that one
ty luang i hope you make costco because
uh it's gonna be a stressful sunday for
my picks
uh quickly in the comments there's some
they're they're on fire
uh andy andy 22ab cam newton two passing
and one rushing rush yeah one rushing
touchdown excuse me
i couldn't get it out because i was like
excited to read it three touchdowns for
killer cam
week one interesting i like that one and
uh and then we got um shout out to titan
golf 14 lamar gets
over 100 yards rushing has one rushing
touchdown
and two passing touchdowns similar to
exactly like um
andy22ab and uh
the the commenter hudson alas i like how
you did this
the odds that i can get a hoodie are
plus ten thousands are you betting on me
cabbie
hudson alaska getting a hoodie okay give
him one sir give him one let's go
you play to my ego and you are rewarded
with an exclusive br betting
all right so the pitches are in uh kelly
now that you've heard the pitches
what advice can you give our squad at
home watching
you know this is going to be interesting
because draftkings is going to boost
whichever one you guys pick i think you
have to take christian mccaffrey here
it's the biggest juice that means it's
more likely to happen than the other two
if
draftkings wants to give us some good
odds i think that's where we have to go
guys
do you mind yeah i mean kelly
kelly i usually don't like to agree with
you you know this
you know this no you know i don't like
to agree
but today we are on the same side we're
one big happy family
i am riding with christian mccaffrey i'm
also riding with the panthers
so you guys that be in my dms asking me
for picks that's who i'm riding with the
panthers
and christian mccaffrey so let's go
all right you guys have all the
information now it's on you
to decide our week one squad ride you
still have time to drop your
favorite picks in the comments
draftkings is boosting the odds
of whatever you pick shout out to
jackboy37 who says what about the jets
people are sleeping on the bet or
le'veon bell after the last
yeah i am not sleeping on
is sleeping on the jets here the jets is
actually my second favorite pick of the
day
you and i were talking about le'veon
before we went on live i do think he
will have himself a day
oh thank you sam darnold's gonna play
really well i like the six and a half
okay okay okay okay i i do like the six
and a half but the jets are not going to
win
i don't think they're gonna well le'veon
don't forget to sprinkle a little bit
guys
le'veon bell no he's he's actually
pretty good he's done
also erin thomas in 98 adds todd gurley
with
20 plus touches gets at least one td
so shout out to the to the few atlanta
falcons fans that are in the comments
all right so while we tally your squad
ride votes we have another hoodie to
give away
earlier asked which mlb hall of famer is
tom brady's landlord a lot of you guys
responded but i'm just gonna pick one of
you
and the winning uh commenter
is that step back
dad step back who chose derek jeter who
is
tom brady's landlord you your my friend
are getting a br betting
hoodie so thank you for for that much
appreciated uh
listen if you didn't get a hoodie don't
sweat
uh keep coming back every sunday we're
gonna be here
giving away the goods and kelly and uh
kelly's got goods to give away in just a
few minutes okay
so it's a moment you have been waiting
for
the week one squad ride votes have been
tallied
and you guys have decided kathy how do
you tally these so fast there's like 8
000 comments there are 8 000 comments
but i've been keeping i've been running
the numbers i have like and this eye is
an ai bot
so this eye has been calculating while
i've been reading
and then just running the tally so and
also the producer said okay we have a we
have an overwhelming
number of picks for our week one squad
ride
we will be on christian mccaffrey to
score a touchdown in week one
against the vegas raiders it is minus
two
and let's get it and kelly and greg
thank you to our friends at draftkings
we're gonna boost that up to plus
300. wait wait wait
what are you serious yeah so we are
riding on
tmc to score a touchdown today
draftkings gave us a sick boost where
it's at plus 300. i love it
so if you want to get the odds boost you
got to go to the field
i'm betting it right now look at him
yeah yeah i'm literally i'm literally
betting this right now like i
plus 300 what okay so for you shout out
drop
like an hour and a half before kickoff
might do we gotta finish the show
i gotta tell people where to get the
link hey shout out draftkey
go to br betting socials to get the link
which will take you to draftkings to get
the odds boost on christian mccaffrey to
score a touchdown so
at br underscore betting on twitter
it'll be up on our our
uh instagram page later but that's where
you get the link to get the odds boost
so boom shout out to our friends at
draftking if it hits
we're giving away more hoodies so make
sure to send us screenshots
of your bets that's important so send us
screenshots of your draftkings bets
to get rewarded with a br betting hoodie
when it hits
because we know cmc is gonna have
himself a day in week one okay so for
those of you
who need a little bit more action we all
know
that our mvp kelly stewart deep dives
into her research
and delivers the goods every football
sunday in fact all week she gives you
guys the goods
but here on the squad ride she has her
best bet so kelly
the stage is yours all right gabby we
got to start off 2020 on a good note
last year these were really fun these
were a good run and i hope we can
continue to do so
question for you guys before i start who
was the most talked about team
and probably quarterback during the off
season that's that's tom brady gronk
it's tampa bay yes tampa bay you guys
nailed it
so what is one of my big favorite things
to do it is about the overreaction in
the marketplace
no disrespect to the goat but it takes
time to learn these new offenses i
really like bruce arians as a head coach
but what we're looking for with teams
that have no mini camp
teams that had no preseason very minimal
practices and walkthroughs
is cohesion who has been the most
complete team over the last few years
and that is the new orleans
saints i'm laying three and a half with
drew brees
alvin kamara michael thomas this is
going to be a fun game
saints are going to come out on top win
the game by a touchdown
uh wow uh this handle
kingdom is my home saints over bucks he
is with you before you even started
he was rocking with you and we got a
bunch of cmc
uh tweets br mikey lux kelly's best bets
this is the way
let's get rich and uh shout out to nisha
says y'all are lit today
much appreciated so the new orleans
saints i
right after this i got to jump on
draftkings to get my bed in two so i
much appreciate it kelly okay
congrats wallow winners i'm hyped it's
football sunday i can't wait to sit in
front of my tv
like you guys and bet on cmc and get
fat because that's what we do week one
fatter
better for some of us uh thank you to
everybody who commented
much appreciated keep an eye out for
this week's squad ride post for a chance
to be featured
in next week's show again shout out to
picks by chicks
shout out to the notorious zach and
shout out to tyler wong
who is saving lives and dropping locks
at work
much appreciated we'll be back next week
out out
same time same place alongside our mvp
kelly stewart and the babyface assassin
greg ivory my name is cabbie richards
enjoy your football sunday good luck
with your bets and peace go panthers